[Music]
pendant les dix jours de verrouillage, nous avons
estimé qu'environ près de 100 millions de
capacité ont été anéanties, puis
après cela, vous savez que nous avons
encore deux semaines de fonctionnement uniquement
à 50% et même que nous  'est-ce que nous
estimons potentiellement une autre
capacité de cent millions de dollars pour être aussi pourquoi
je ne doute pas que dans les prochains
mois, vous savez que la situation
ne devrait pas s'améliorer, il y aura une pénurie de
préservatifs sur le marché
[Musique]
en fait  en ce moment, nous commençons vraiment
à voir une augmentation des coûts, vous savez, en termes
de fabrication, car nous avons gagné
tous nos employés au complet et seulement 50%
de la main-d'œuvre arrivent, le monde
devra probablement se pencher un
peu plus, vous savez  le préservatif deviendra probablement
un peu plus cher Je pense que beaucoup
de choses vont devenir plus chères
[Musique]